you wake up the alarm goes off what do
you do what so you're not even vertical
and you're reading emails if you're not
smart car yourself dumb you want to talk
so soft to herself we're looking for
that recovery day if you're gonna watch
The Godfather baby I watch The Godfather
for what what did you watch The
Godfather before what did you learn when
you was watching it want to be happy
build a life not just a business what's
up believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
today let's live your best belief life
and learn the ten habits that you must
adopt also if you want to know what Mel
Robbins Eric Thomas David Goggins and
others have to say about confidence and
excellence check out my to 54 series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
links to join are in the description
below if you didn't give a [ __ ] what
anybody else thought what's the thing
you would love to be doing with your
life I have boundaries everything I
didn't want to do is what got me to
where I'm at today
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one get rid of your phone with Mel
Robbins
there is one habit that I have adopted
in the last three years that has
fundamentally changed me as a business
person and it has also changed my
ability to manage my emotions so I don't
get hijacked I do not allow my phone in
the bedrooms I know the research the
light just did a study based on phone
use alone and 33 percent of people are
reading emails in the middle of the
night I know that if you go to bed and
the phone is right next to you right so
you go to bed because you need your
phone you know if somebody might need
you and you sleep you know if this is
right here and it's not closed and the
blue light is on they've done studies
where you have people at a table and the
researcher will put their phone on the
table not even my phone
the researchers phone and the brain
lights up like crazy just with the
presence of a phone the research around
the phone and sleep is so stunning that
if you were to adopt one radical thing
today other than the five-second rule
try putting your phone outside your
bedroom
turn off the big little visit so you
don't hear it tell people who need to
reach you to call you my kids I had a
kid in college a kid who's you know high
school kid in middle school if there's
an emergency call me there is nothing
happening on your phone at two o'clock
in the morning that's important but if
you allow yourself to become a tool of
this this is supposed to be your tool
for selling your tool for communicating
and we're all becoming the tool here's
the other thing common sense wise that I
want you to understand you wake up the
alarm goes off what do you do so you're
not even vertical and you're reading
emails
and what is in these emails other
people's crap but you don't have
boundaries with this puppy it's gonna
impact sleep it's gonna affect how much
money money it's going to get back to my
self-control you have and so whenever I
put this thing outside the bedroom and I
wake up I walk over to where the phone
is it's plugged into my bathroom I turn
it off I don't look at it again I give
myself five minutes five minutes before
I tune into the world it's actually
tuned in up here and today what's the
one thing I'm gonna get done today that
really matters to me if you're the kind
of person that feels like you don't have
control over your day that your day gets
hijacked that you can't get to the
priorities that you're always behind the
ball
this one planning thing will change your
life no phone in the bedroom turn it off
when the alarm goes off five minutes
five lousy minutes five thousand minutes
before you tune in to the rest of the
world and if you've got the kind of job
where you've got to check it get up ten
minutes earlier you have control over
this stuff and it is so important that
you take it seriously now because you're
living at the slowest moment of your
entire life how about number two change
your mentality with David Goggins so
many people before I give them a workout
playing they talk about recovery
everybody everybody that hears me speak
they want to go straight to recovery
work out first huh work out first before
you talk to me about recovery how to
recover yeah
work out first we are always looking for
like whenever I talk to people people
take my words and they and they and they
put it in a way to where they want to
feel comfortable this guy you know they
they they want to put you in a box they
want to put a title on you know you're
putting a title on me to make yourself
feel better about yourself if you read
this book of mine and you see where I
came from
this person went that this person was
not built this business that this person
was not made by God mm-hmm this person
saw this person was built
I made this person I made this person by
diving in to the insecurities that life
gave me because now they're yours do
yours to own if you're not smart car
yourself dumb it's okay
because you are but take that knowledge
of putting
down if you're fat Carly so fat I used
to be 300 pounds mmm we we want to talk
so soft to our self we're looking for
that recovery day in that recovery day
is everything in your life everything in
your life is that recovery day we're
looking for it it's not coming it's not
coming get over there recovery day and
that's the mentality I took with me and
what happened through that process was
all the frivolous things of life started
to float away I have to tell people lies
so they would like me hmm cuz I was so
insecure when you start to build
yourself up it start to have the one
thing that we don't have is confidence
yeah real authentic confidence from hard
work everything else goes away you no
longer look to other people for your
selfish down days it's like oh yeah you
know no I walk in the room now and I
know the hours in years and decades I'm
put in a day to Goggins that's something
it's not on the wall it's not a trophy
on the wall it's not a melon on your
neck it is actually a feeling in your
heart and people why don't you ever
smile I don't have to yeah yeah I do
have a store look at my face but I'm a
very focused person but the thing I have
in my soul in my heart that's what I
need to smile I don't need to smile I
don't need you to look at me and say oh
my god you look happy because help us
aren't happy mm-hmm right we're giving
you something that we think you want to
see I don't do anymore I don't care how
you perceive David Gardens they get us
do my journey I figured out the one
piece I was missing I thought it was
cars I thought it was women I thought it
was my body but I thought was everything
the one piece I was missing was me
having the courage to face myself how
about number three always over deliver
with Robin Sharma
it is so rare in business and in society
right now to see people that
consistently go the extra mile you're in
a restaurant the server generally gives
you what you expect or less than what
you expect you go into a clothing store
it's what you expect or less than what
you expect
you do business with any organization
it's generally delivering on what you
expect but more often even less so you
have a gorgeous opportunity to lead the
field in everything that you do by doing
one thing practicing every single day
because it's a muscle the ritual of over
delivering don't just give your
customers what they expect
give them 10x more than what they expect
don't just give your organization what
your manager what your boss what the
organization is expecting from you show
something that is so rare in today's
economy initiative initiative so you're
asked to do a project give them five
more things than they expect you're
asked to give a presentation on
something go the extra mile
consistently dial in the daily habit of
over delivering on people's expectations
and guess what you become a merchant of
Wow you become indispensable to your
organization habit number four apply
what you learned with Eric Thomas you
know you got to be careful what I this
motivation in the books you read yeah
but you got to be careful that you're
not doing it like for entertainment you
feel me and I think a lot of you do it
for entertainment so it's like I'm
watching Serina play that's purely other
than the fact that I'm gonna take some
of the content and use it you know the
speed that's purely entertainment
I'm just watching her do what she do
that's pure entertainment and so for
some of you when you when you listen to
motivation you're not using it to fuel
you you feel me like you need to use it
to fuel you so let's just say you can do
real estate are you scared like you
should you should be listening to
specific stuff that's gonna tell you
don't be afraid take risk let the Rope
go let the neck go like that's what you
should be listening to not risk random
stuff you know I'm saying like we put
stuff out but we're putting it out
because that's what we do we just put
stuff out but you got to get a catalog
and say alright I'm fearful or I don't
got that dog and if you doing business
you gotta have that dog
so you just got listen to a whole bunch
of stuff I see people walk around with
the t-shirts you out look yourself in
the mirror I got that dog like whatever
it is you need then when you give books
I'm tired of people like oh it's like a
like a keeping up with the Jones is not
like you know what book you read for
what wait it's like you telling me what
book you read for what like just so you
can sound deep you're not doing them
with the information you filled me like
you just trying to be like in
conversation like drinking coffee and
say oh yeah I read that with grit I read
grit grit was phenomenal but you don't
got no more grit I'm just saying you
don't have no more grease than you
started when you first read the book so
it's like instead of reading a book and
trying to be deep like what is the book
saying like how do you acquire grit if
you don't got none do me a favor
stop reading to be deep right some of
you are watching power you don't got a
little more power after watching power
are you gonna watch it [ __ ] watch what
episode like that ain't necessarily my
thing but I'm saying if you're gonna
watch it from what I'm hearing it's um
it's um cats on there who straight-up
gangsters so if you're gonna watch it be
gangsters like for real don't watch it
and don't be gangster if you're gonna
watch it and you gonna put that stuff in
your spirit if you're gonna watch The
Godfather baby but I watch The Godfather
for what what did you watch The
Godfather before what did you learn when
you was watching it you watch Scarface
what'd you learn I learned some stuff
from Scarface flat out flat out I
learned some stuff right and my wife get
on me all the time
you don't I'm like yo I've seen the
movie I grew up in the hood flat out and
system stuff that I'm conscious I'm
aware of so I'm told
ain't no don't get knocked down on me
and I ain't gonna get shot up you
understand what I'm telling you like I'm
aware of always of what's happening you
feel me so don't be why I watch Scarface
I went to the movie and saw it I still
remember the movie to this day I still
remember when my with the women thing
how the woman theme messed the whole
mess a whole little swag up though I
remember his New Jack city and stuff
happen where the power wasn't equal and
that I Pais I watch the movie so you
watching it but you ain't paying
attention to it and I'm paying attention
so stop watching that stuff and not
doing them with it
habit number five fix yourself with
Patrick baited the fifth one is directed
to those of you that are always
can have people insane this person must
change you he must change her she must
change here but there's one person you
never look at and that's yourself so
what's the solution and 2019 make an
effort to study every single one of your
trends
let me explain to what I mean by
studying your trend the next time you're
angry get a paper and pen and write down
exactly what caused you to be angry if
you're depressed if you're agitated if
all of a sudden you're having a division
with somebody you've been very good for
four six twelve months why are you all
of a sudden angry at this person why are
you taking things out on this person
maybe you just spoke to your ex and
maybe your ex doesn't like this person
and every time you talk to your ex he
says well you know how he is you know
how she is and all of us and you're
taking it out on this person what
happened there study your trends and
when you get lazy study your trends and
when you get urgent when you work harder
when you're positive when you're happy
when you're fired up when all of a
sudden people want to be around you when
do people not want to be around you what
causes it
20:19 study yourself the way the best
hedge fund managers study stocks and
look how quickly you'll start changing
many of your bad habits with good ones
habit number six look for positivity
with Gary Vaynerchuk you find what
you're looking for I've been giving a
lot of thought to kind of just watching
what I'm seeing out there in the social
digital ecosystem and very honestly just
real life and I'm watching so many
people over the last two to three years
look for negativity look for something
that's wrong find where people disagree
with them fight look for what was me
downside the half glass empty and then I
go to a Twitter search or look around
the world and I find ridiculously
beautiful things every day every day
thousands of kind acts randomly by
people all people that I have
conversations with who see the
opportunities whether it's in business
like voice and AR or crypto or whatever
it may be just this amazingly
interesting thing that I feel the
majority of you are looking for the
wrong while there's plenty of wrong and
play
right in the world it comes down to one
very simple thing what are you choosing
to look for because I promise you if you
right now and I'm making this video for
one reason 24 hours of trying to find
the good somebody saves a kid somebody
opens the door somebody does a nice
thing for you bit somebody says thank
you 24 hours of looking for positivity
could change your life honestly making
this for one person one one person
watches this video chooses to do 24
hours of looking for good instead of
looking for bad and their game changes
d-roc heard somebody at a convenience
store saying mom you're always so
negative you're always so negative I am
blown away by the fact that life gets
real simple if you break down into this
are you looking for the negative this
sucks this government sucks this person
sucks this is are you looking for the
positive she's nice that's remarkable
I've got this opportunity you choose
what you're looking for because what you
look for you find that's how life works
habit number seven be more energetic
with day in lock you don't have enough
energy how do you expect to accomplish
anything significant accomplish your
goals when you don't have enough energy
you notice the society puts down and
look down on people they have high
energy imagine you're going to school
you're going to work you're going back
to your office you're going back to your
business and suddenly you're so
energetic and you have your all hyped up
what would people say to you what's
wrong with you dude like calm them down
relax why are you so excited
but somehow you have no energy in man
that's okay
you know what Feinstein stands for
freaked out in debt not making enough
money emotionally stressed out f ing
that's what it stands for hi my name is
fine
that's what fine words but somehow
you've high energy it is wrong you want
to have energy you got to move laughing
my martial art background you watch my
video you follow my work you know move
jumping jack pushup walk yoga whatever
the it takes move your body but you move
you have more energy when you sit there
all day for hours how the hell can you
have energy movement creates energy so
if you're sitting there for a long day
get up stand up walk around do something
I know jumpin up and down water it is do
something habit number eight
stop all poverty behavior with Grant
Cardone stop all poverty behavior
poverty is a terrible thing if you've
ever known anybody lived in poverty
suffer with poverty even close to the
poverty line you know that it is awful
and even those with money can live like
they are in poverty I have known
millionaires that acted like they were
in poverty wouldn't spend any of the
money they had because they were worried
about money not coming in in the future
make a list of all the actions because
most of this is mental make a list of
all action those who live in poverty
operate with and commit to not doing
them listen to what I'm saying here make
a list of the activities that people
that either live in poverty or act like
they're living in poverty how they
operate everyday
drugs alcohol buying stuff not investing
but spending wasting weekend's
government or any kind of dependence
upon others shortcuts victim mentality
not reading refusing the network and
refusing to get outside your zip code
and travel or all things that you need
to stop and I'm sure you could expand
this list
stop all poverty behavior how about
number nine enhance the quality of your
sleep with rich roll wrench
why do you sleep in a tent for those
that don't know for the last two years
I've been sleeping outside in this thing
a lot of people have been asking me why
did you do that and it basically boils
down to three fundamental reasons the
first is I just sleep better in a tent
outside the second reason is that it
really has helped me connect with nature
and the outdoors and I think our primal
disposition and the third reason I've
been doing it is because fundamentally
it's a stoic practice a couple years ago
I started struggling with trying to get
a deep sleep unless I was training
SuperDuper hard I just found it
difficult to get the restfulness that my
body and my mind need and at the time
our bedroom that I share with my wife
Julie was either too cold for her or too
hot for me then I had an experience
where we as a family all slept on our
roof one night we have a flat roof and
we did it just for fun with the kids and
I had the most restful peaceful night of
sleep in recent memory being outdoors
breathing that outdoor air sleeping
under the stars is a very simple and
basic way of reconnecting with what it
means to be fundamentally human we live
in this super fast-paced culture you got
to get your hustle on you gotta like
work 24 hours a day and if you're not
being productive in every moment of your
waking existence then you're wasting
time and you're falling behind and with
that comes a deep prioritization of
sleep sleep is for slackers right and
nothing could be further from the truth
I know that I can't perform at my very
best unless I get eight hours of sleep
and it's not just the amount of time
that I sleep it's the quality of that
sleep it's the caliber of that sleep it
is my opinion that everybody should be
doing everything they can to enhance
that quality of their
evening hours and I found that by
sleeping in a tent it's almost like this
hack towards improving the calibre of my
sleep so that I can show up throughout
my day and excel be totally focused be
totally present have good energy be in a
good mood and all of that derives from
sleep so if you really take the time to
prioritize the quality and the amount of
time that you're sleeping every night
you will realize quantum gains in your
productivity in your output throughout
your day in habit number 10 the last one
before very special bonus have it is
don't hit the snooze button with Jocko
willing don't press snooze snooze
doesn't help snooze is one of the things
that just serves as a dream killer yeah
it's like a sister's Bob Odenkirk dreams
that score that's it that's right yeah
it's like a complete think it's gonna
help you dream more but it's not
stressful psychological trick if you
pursues the thing that you think
pressing the snooze helps you with like
I'll just get that extra eight minutes
asleep that eight minutes asleep Billy
give me any more energy by the way 18
seconds there's a there's an 18 second
window in the morning when your alarm
goes off that sucks
it's about 18 seconds so 18 3 alarm goes
off in Utah [ __ ]
the next 18 seconds are like hard there
that's when you have to use maximum
effort to clear the gravitational pull
of your pillow
if you can get away from those 18
seconds then you're okay
you just get a get away from the pillow
it's pulling you in some tractor fever I
need to get away from that and so that
18 seconds and once you're up you're
moving you're good
now I've got a really special bonus tip
with Patrick Bay debate on how to stop
changing your mind that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that I
decide for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to taking action
in your life or business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one will you commit to no longer
hitting the snooze button number two
what poverty behavior must you stop and
number three what negative mentality of
yours must change
the first one is very specific to those
of you that change your mind very very
often it's a bad habit and it's costing
you relationships friendships and
success in business let me explain what
I mean by this no matter what business
you choose to do they're all ugly no
business is pretty it's like a
relationship
there isn't anything you're gonna do in
the world of business that's gonna be
all good and dandy nothing not a single
business however this is a common trend
you see what a lot of people none of us
like to lose but some people when they
lose they respond in three different
ways one is fries they don't know what
to say the other one is they go and
fight and the last one is they flight
you know what flight is they change
their minds I don't want to do this
anymore and they run away you know why
because they're afraid of commitment
very simple in the world of business in
real world of business if you want to
win a 20-19 if you keep changing your
mind
nobody is gonna take you seriously
if you want to know the eight must-have
skills for the modern world check out
the video there right next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you an entrepreneur
you got a product people are asking
three questions who are you what do you
have and why should I care